Speaker 1: Let's go next to Dean from Dallas.
Dean from Dallas. Welcome to The David Pakman
Show. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David.
I called in a couple of times. I don't know
if you remember me, but I wanted to ask a
couple of questions. You know, there are these
buzzwords which are often associated with, like,
a political party. Like when you hear patriotism
or freedom, you think of the right wing or MAGA.
Why doesn't the left attempt to take the positive
ones back? Why do we can see those terms that can
obviously apply to the party in big ways?
Speaker 1: We've talked about this before.
I think it's actually a great idea. Like when we
talk about what it means to be patriotic. There's
a very cartoonish version on the right. And for
me, you know, patriotism would be, hey, you know
what? I take pride in my country making sure no
one is starving, that no one is homeless. It's
like that would be a new form of patriotism that I
think would be much more interesting and inspiring
and positive. I can't answer the question why have
Democrats or the left not taken back these terms?
There's a bunch of writing about this. George
Lakoff has talked about Republicans winning
the framing war. You know, I, I unfortunately,
Dean, I can't tell you why Democrats or the left
haven't done it. But you're absolutely right in
diagnosing that a lot of these terms have been
kind of perverted and certainly used exclusively
by the right to have narrow meanings and the left
should try to take them back. But I don't
really know what the first step would be.
Speaker 2: Yeah. And then I had a second question,
if you don't mind. Sure. Do you have any thoughts
on cultural assimilation? Do you think it's more
positive or negative, or does it make us stronger
as a country or. What are your opinions on it?
Speaker 1: Well, I think that when people talk
about cultural assimilation, usually it's
often used to draw a very specific political
perspective out of people. And my view on cultural
assimilation is, I think one of the things that
makes the United States great is that you do have
all of these different cultures that when things
are going well, can can sort of coexist. And I
think it's actually a great thing. And also, I
recognize that there are difficulties that surface
if you have different types of division, like when
people talk about, hey, this is America, we speak
English here. Yet, listen, I mean, in a practical
sense, in order to best communicate, it's good to
have a shared language. So I agree with the idea
that if someone comes to the United States and
lives in the United States for 30 years and speaks
no English, that's going to be an impediment both
for them and for the rest of society to relate. I
also think it's a great thing to understand and
respect and embrace different cultures, and that
includes different languages and bilingualism
and all of these different things so that the,
you know, to say is cultural assimilation, good
or bad To some degree, if we're all going to live
together, we need to have some shared touch points
and language, respect for different religions,
respect for different countries of origins. All
of these different things are really important.
But to objectively just say cultural assimilation
is good or bad gets us into the kind of black and
white thinking that often gets us nowhere.
Speaker 2: Yeah, it kind of seems like our
country as a whole is just it's a constant
battle since we're so split of like what
the new American dream or the American way of
living is like. It used to be like own a house,
you know, have kids married, get and get a good
job, go to college and all the things, you know,
like it's kind of shifting. And, you know, people
like right wing conservative players are saying,
you know, college is where you go to get
work. Don't go to college or whatever.
It's. It's and you know, where people are
making more social protest. It's like during
like the Pledge of Allegiance or, you know,
the singing of The Star-Spangled Banner or
people not standing. You know, it's kind of. Yeah.
Speaker 1: And to be clear, for me, the Pledge of
Allegiance is just so silly. I don't even consider
it when I think about an issue like cultural
assimilation. It's just nonsense to me.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Speaker 1: You know. All right. Dean from Dallas,
appreciate the call. Great questions. Thank you.
All right. There goes Dean from Dallas.
Very, very powerful topics, I must say